close friends of the yoga teacher shot
and killed by Minneapolis police officer
are speaking out for the first time
Justine Gaiman was killed Saturday
minutes after calling 911 sexual assault
near her home transcripts of her calls
were released yesterday
those who knew daymond are calling her
death senseless
Jamie yuccas has been in Minneapolis
with an interview you will only see on
CBS this morning Jamie good morning good
morning Justine Damon's death has moved
complete strangers to leave flowers and
cards at the spiritual center where she
taught those in her inner circle say
this loss has been devastating I talked
to those closest to her who hoped the
worldwide attention brings lasting
change we're all trying to ease the pain
in some way Carol and Tom Haider have
spent much of the last week consoling
Justine Damon's fiance Don and his son
Zach it was Tom who first told Zach
Justine was gone he just set back and
got quiet I mean you could start to see
him get angry and then you could but the
disbelief it was just steam of all
people Damon called 911 27 p.m. Saturday
because she thought a woman was being
raped in the alley behind her home I
think she tried to say help
and it sounds distressed she told the
operator eight minutes later with no
police in sight she called again no
one's here and was wondering if they got
the address wrong officers Muhammad nor
and Matthew harity responded harity
drove the police vehicle down the alley
according to investigators the officers
lights and body cameras were off harity
told state investigators he was startled
by a loud sound when they reached the
end of the alley
just before Damon appeared by his door
in her pajamas Noor fired a single fatal
shot from the passenger seat the alley
is lit I can't imagine what she would
have done that would have alarmed
anybody Hara DS attorney Fred Bruno told
CBS News it is reasonable to assume an
officer in that situation would be
concerned about a possible ambush nor
who is smally American joined the police
department two years ago the Damon
family's attorney says he will be
looking closely at Norris training
records and how he was hired we don't
want politically approved police
officers we want properly trained police
officers you guys also feel some
training needs to happen or some changes
need to happen yeah and I guess my hope
and senses that will happen not that it
needs type and it will happen this time
the mayor of Minneapolis says that
officer Noir is a fully trained police
officer and he will not be treated any
differently than anyone else in this
investigation however officer Norris
still has not talked to investigators
Charlie thanks Jamie